>>male presenter:Welcome everybody. It is
my distinct pleasure to welcome Matt Ridley
today to Google. So, I don't know about you
but I've heard the saying, "nuclear fusion
is about 20 years in the future every time
you ask a fusion physicists." It may not be
true apparently people at Lawrence Livermore
are doing something to change that, but it's
been true for the last 50 years. So there's
a category of people who have sort of the
same saying. They say, "well you know, our
civilization is doomed. You know like in the
next six months we'll see everything collapse
and the world will change as we know it. We
are over using the planet. We are not doing
the right things." Well, our guest today will
hopefully disprove this notion. He's written
a great book which I recommend to all of you
to read, check it out. It's called the, Rational
Optimist and it deals with some of the issues
of society today.
Matt Ridley is the author of proactive books
on evolution, genetics, and society. His books
have sold over 800 copies--800,000 copies,
I'm sorry!
[audience mumbling, laughing]
[audience member clapping]
Been translated into 27 languages, have won
several awards including: the award for "the
Best Science Book published in 2003" from
the National Academy of Science, and the Los
Angeles Times book prize.
The Rational Optimist has been categorized
As the trumpet blast against despair. Let's
see if Matt can tip our way of thinking about
the world for the better. Please welcome Matt
Ridley.
[audience applause]
>>Matt Ridley: Thank you, Boris very much
indeed, and it's a terrific honor to be here
at Google. I was thinking the other day that
actually the technology that's changed my
life as an author most in my lifetime is probably
the search engine. It is truly as revolutionary,
I think, in my life--what I do as--as the
steam engine was in my great--my ancestors'
lifetimes. So what I want to do today is some,
here's a 20 seconds summary of the talk. First
of all, I want to to make the case that ideas
have sex and that's where innovation comes
from; that exchange has the same impact on
economic progress that sexual reproduction
has on biological evolution. It's a specific
analogy that I will expel out. Uh. The effect,
the reason that progress happens is essentially
because everybody works for everybody else
which is great theme of human history. It's
a habit that started 120,000 years ago. It
results in something called "collective intelligence"
whereby the knowledge of how to do things
to make things is stored across society not
within our brains. The results is that things
are actually getting better not worse. People
are surprisingly getting nicer and we ain't
seen nothing yet, and the global pessimists
are wrong. So those are the topics I'll try
and cover in the next 40 minutes or so.
Very clear-
I went to be very clear what I'm not saying.
I'm not saying everything is fine in the world
quite the reverse. I actually think it's because
there's so much still wrong with the world
that we need to understand how much better
we can make it. I'm not saying nothing's getting
worse, there are things getting worse in the
world of course there are trends that are
going in the wrong direction. And I'm certainly
not saying that everything is fine in any
one individual country. We're clearly in the
middle of the terrible financial crisis in
the West at the moment. We've managed in this
crisis to actually shrink the world economy
in 2009, but only by 1%. Globally though now
China is growing at 12%, the world at 4%.
So, my focus is global it's not local in this.
And I'm not saying, you know, that you need
to sort be individually happy or anything
like that. This isn't about individual optimism
this is about optimism for the species. In
some respects people are too optimistic about
their own lives, and not optimistic enough
about the species. For example, people think
they're going to stay married longer than
they do.
I want to end up by having you asked the question,
whenever anybody says pessimist things to
you, "On what principle is it that when we
see nothing but improvement behind us, we
are to expect nothing but deterioration before
us?" And that was said 1830, and it's even
more true today.
So essentially what I want to start by doing
is explaining how we went from making things
like that to making things like that. These
are both real objects they sit on my desk
at home they are identical in size and shape
and yet of course a very different. The one
on the left is made from one material the
one on the right is a confection of lots of
different substances and has a huge complexity
within it. And the one on the left, which
is called an Acheulean handaxe, was made to
roughly the same design for nearly a million
years. Homo erectus made these things, and
he made them incredibly well. He was very
good at them, but they were the same all over
the world and they were the same for a million
years. It's quite unimaginable to us that
a technology which stand still in that way.
But during Homo erectus' time his body changed
faster than his toolkit. That's an extraordinary
idea. We think that when we invented tools
we must invented innovation, too. It didn't
happen. Technology came before innovation.
The object on the right is obsolete already
after five years. So let me start by making
the case that exchange is the thing that has
accelerated cultural change in the way sex
accelerated biological change.
Culture is a combinatorial thing. It brings
together ideas, it reorganizes atoms and electrons
in different combinations. So every technology
we look at is actually a combination of other
technologies and of other ideas. And its ideas
coming together in changing each other that
is innovation in a way--is to some of the
things going to making bicycle, they are all
different. And in order to be combinatorial,
in order to be cumulative you need to have
process of exchange. And it's the same in
biological evolution. My body is also a combination
of inventions. Different proteins, different
genes, different cell types that have all
come together. We were all diff--invented
in different places, at different times, by
different organisms and they've all come together
in me and indeed in you. How did that happen?
Well ,sex was absolutely key to that. The
invention of sexual reproduction. Let me explain.
If you imagine an asexual animal an animal
that simply gives birth mother to son--mother
to daughter rather--without any males forever,
then what's going to happen if you have mutations--good
ones--is that they're going through in competition
with each other. So if you invent the green
thing and somebody else invents the red thing.
Natural selection is going to have to decide
which one is better and make the other one
extinct. So imagine this is an ancestral mammal
and one of them invents milk and the other
one invents the placenta and we have to decide
which of these two innovations we want in
the species. But if they're having sex then
of course at some point you can get an organism
that has both of these. So, the effect of
sex--the invention of sexual reproduction--enabled
evolution to become cumulative and combinatorial.
It wasn't the case before that.
Now the invention of exchange had the same
impact on cultural evolution. Because you
can actually have cultural without sex--as
it were, you know--you can have culture without
exchange. And the effect is you get no cumulative
combina--combinatorial. Chimpanzees have culture's,
they have traditions of how to break open
nuts with rocks. And the fascinating thing
is that if you go to different parts of Africa--indeed
even to different parts of the same forest--you'll
find different troops of chimpanzees have
different cultures, different traditions of
how to break open rocks. And they--because
they never trade they never exchange. You
can't get the ideas coming together and therefore
culture never builds. It's not progressive,
it's not cumulative in these animals. That's
what's different about us, not that we've
got culture, but we've got cumulative combinatorial
culture. And it's this process of exchange,
this process of swapping things with each
other that's had a huge impact on our development.
So why is it? Why does exchange cause innovation?
Why does exchange raise living standards,
indeed? And the answer really is a pretty
old one. David Ricardo, a stockbroker, in
England in the early 19th century coined a
thing called "the Law of Comparative Advantage".
He was talking about international trade,
but I want to rephrase it in stone age terms.
There are two guys sitting around a fire called
Adam and Oz. Adam takes four hours to make
a spear and three hours to make an ax. Oz
Is better at making both spears and axes than
Adam. Adam doesn't-so Oz doesn't need Adam
does he? You know, Adams is a waste of space
as far as Oz is concerned. Well no, because
all Oz has to do is make two spears and get
Adam to make two axes and then they trade.
And the result is that they've both saved
an hour of work each. That's the law of comparative
advantage. Now the point is, that if they
do that a couple of times then Oz is going
to get even better at making spears and Adam
is going to get even better at making axes.
So it's going to be even more true every time
they do it that there are going to be gains
from trade in it. And that's the story of
human progress really. It's the specialization
that each of us, we get more and more specialized
as producers and that enables us to be more
and more diversified as consumers. Because
in the end what we're doing is we're all working
for each other.
Go back to this image of the stone ax and
the computer mouse. The stone ax was made
by one man for his own use. We actually know
this because you can find archeological sites
where they were made and you can find the
chips how they fell from the Boulder as the
man was chipping it. And you can see that
five people were sitting around after they
killed a horse. And this is one particular
case in southern England 500,000 years ago.
And they each made their own ax to help butcher
the animal. The object on the right was made
for me very kindly by lots of people. Tens
of people, hundreds of people, thousands of
people I think it's millions of people actually
when you think about it. Because it's not
just the man who assembled the computer mouse.
It's the man who drilled oil well to get the
oil to make the plastic to house it. And the
man who brewed coffee for the man he drilled
oil well and so on. Once you start counting
the number of people who contributed to making
me that computer mouse just when I needed
it, there were an awful lot of them. A million
people working for me. It's an extraordinary
phenomenon.
Here's a rich man, Louis XIV, the King of
France in the late 17th century. And he's
rich because he had a lot of people working
for him. He had--he could get almost anything
he wanted because he could ask people to make
it for him or to do it for him. So somebody
made that silly outfit he's wearing for example
and somebody precious hair in that strange
way and Louis XIV had 498 people to cook his
dinner every night. Which is quite a good
number, but an ordinary modern tourist in
the Palace of Versailles looking at Louis
XIV's possessions today--she's not rich and
yet when you think about it she's got people
working for her. Somebody made those jeans.
Somebody made the electricity that's lighting
the room, and she has cut 498 people to cook
her dinner tonight. They're all in restaurants
and cafés and shops all over Paris but within
an hour's drive she could find at least 498
people ready to serve her meal at very short
notice. What's the difference? That's essentially
the process of prosperity--is increasingly--that
we've worked for each other.
Now this happens in other animals, too. ”The
division of labor", Adam Smith called it or
exchange in specialization. And it happens
in, for example, social insects like ants--where
this is a worker ant feeding a queen ant.
But there's one big difference in all other
examples of animals which work for each other,
they do it within the family. An ant colony
is just a big family. Everybody is the daughter
of the queen, essentially. And so they do
not ever work for strangers. The one division
of labor that always have is a reproductive
division of labor, so that only one individual
reproduces. You get a specialist casts that
reproduces, the queen. That's the one division
of labor we never do human society. It's the
one specialization--we don't have specialized
breeders in our society. We have specialized
producers and everything else that not even
in England in the production to the queen.
[Audience laughter]
And of course agriculture is same idea. It's
working not just for each other and for other
species and other species working for us.
So, for example, ants also an indulgent agriculture
in the sense that they farm aphids. Here's
an ant on the left taking honeydew from an
aphid and working for the aphid--in the sense
of guarding it--and the aphid is working for
it. But human agriculture is the same. The
shepherd on the right is working for the sheep
and the sheep are working for the shepherd
and the dog is working for both of them and
so on. That's what agriculture is. Its species
working for each other.
Now I'm going to argue that this habit of
working for each other, of specialization
in exchange, began around 120,000 years ago.
And I'm going to present some evidence for
that. And it explains human take off. Explains
how we went from being very clever, very linguistic
all these kinds of things, but still having
no great--what you might call--explosion of
numbers or prosperity to becoming a species
that totally dominates the planet. Because
if you look at a graph of human brain size
over time--from fossils--like this one, you
can see that it's a pretty gradual process,
the increase in brain size. And if you put
on this--the great things that we think make
us human, that distinguish us from other animals,
they all come at the wrong time to explain
what's going on. So for example standing on
two legs, well, that happened at least 2 1/2
million years ago.
Yesterday I was handling a replica of Ardipithecus
ramidus. The 4.4 million-year-old ancestral
species which was pretty well bipedal already
4.4 million years ago. So, freeing
up the hands had an impact, but it wasn't
the key ingredient. You mention of tools,
stone tools are 2 1/2 million years old. Fire,
we don't know when it happened maybe half
million may be 1 1/2 million years ago. And
it had a big impact because once we'd invented
fire, we could do cooking, and that's external
digestion which means you don't need to such
a big gut, so you can have a bigger brain
etc. etc. But it comes too early in the story.
Even language, we now know Neanderthals probably
had the same mutations in the genome that
facilitate language that we did. Which means
that our common ancestor with Neanderthals
400,000 or so years ago probably had incipient
language. So, it doesn't look like language
had quite the impact we often thought it did.
My argument is that exchange comes at just
the right time. The invention of swapping
things which was a very difficult thing to
invent because their homicidal relations between
troops of apes usually. Came around the right
time to explain the sudden transformation
is just another successful but relatively
rare ape into the creatures that dominates
the planet. It may have been preceded--perhaps--by
an older division of labor which probably
preconditioned us to this. And this is sexual
division of labor, the division of labor between
males and females. In all extant hunter gatherer
society as a specialization in the way creatures
forage between males and females. It is usually
hunting males and gathering females but it's
not always quite that simple. So for example
in the Hadza here, men go out hunting for
things like warthogs and women go digging
for roots. Now it's a beautiful system because
has a wonderful Ricardian gains from trade
in it. All a women has to do if she wants
protein is dig up some extra roots. So as
to have something to trade for food. She doesn't
have to go out on an exhausting hunt. And
all a man has to do to have a plentiful supply
of food, even on days when he hasn't managed
to catch anything, is make sure that when
he does catch something it's big enough so
that he can share the meat with a woman. Both
sides benefit from the system. It's a beautiful
invention. And it looks like that it was something
that Neanderthal might not have had. Neanderthals
were--they're an enigma, they're highly intelligent
creatures. They have on average bigger brains
than us. The probably one of the biggest fossil
craniums that's ever been found was neanderthal.
They, as I said, they had imagination, because
they buried their dead. They had language.
The puzzle--and yet they, their technology
did not progress. It remained very similar
until the last few thousand years, before
they went extinct. And their numbers didn't
change. They had nothing like the kind of
take off that we did. They certainly didn't
invent civilization. And it looks like they
didn't have a sexual division of labor. This
is the theory of Mary Stein and Steve Kuhner--it's
the other way around--Mary Stiner and Steve
Kuhn at Arizona, who argue that you look at
Neanderthals sites you can't find the sorts
of toolkits and objects that women would've
been using if they were like hunter-gatherers.
There's no plant processing tools, there's
no Grindstones, there's no clothes making,
all those kinds of things. So, they're not
saying that women did nothing, they're saying
actually that women were probably out hunting
with men and that this was a highly cooperative
species in which everybody helped each other
but they didn't have a distinction between
the roles of the males and females, they were
all hunters. And we know that Neanderthals
did not trade because Neanderthal tools are
always made from local materials. The stone
tools were made from rocks found within just
a very short distance from where they are.
Whereas, modern human tools after 100,000
years as ago start cropping up were made from
things a long, long way away. For example
in the Caucuses there is a site where the
Neanderthal remains on one side of the valley
and modern human remains on the other. The
Neanderthal remains are associated with the
local chert. And the modern human remains
are associated with obsidian from up to 100
miles away. So the earliest evidence for trade
is when things start moving long distances.
And in Ethiopia you see stone tools starting
to move long distances around 100,000 years
ago something similar and Algeria where these
marine shells are moving 125 miles inland...
What happened? Did it go--has it gone a funny
color?
[Mumbling]
Can you see this clearly?--Well the image
is very dark.
So these marine shells which have been drilled
to make beads and have been worn smooth by
being worn probably on a string. These date
from at least 80,000 and probably up to 120,000
years ago. And this is the first time were
saying objects moving long distances. How
do we know that moving long distances is trade
and not migration? Well, because in relatively
modern Stone Age people like Australian Aborigines
he could see the same phenomenon. There was
a quarry called Mount Isa in northern Australia
where the Kalkadoon tribe dug up stone axes.
And they traded them with their neighbors
for things like stingray barbs. And as a result
of the stone axes ended up all over Australia
in a far larger area than the Kalkadoon tribe
ever went to.
And what happens when you cut a human off
from trade and exchange networks? Well, one
of the fascinating natural experiments
… in this is what happened to Tasmanian
Aborigines. They occupied Tasmania 35,000
years ago when it was firs--when it was a
peninsula of the Australian continent. About
10,000 years ago the sea levels rose at the
end of the ice age in Tasmania was cut off
and became an island. Over the next 10,000
years to 4,000 or so people living on Tasmania
not only experience and no progressive innovations
in the tools that they were making, they actually
experienced regress. Their tools became simpler
and they lost certain technologies altogether.
They lost the ability to make bone tools for
example lost the ability to make fishing equipment.
And they lost the ability to make clothing.
What's going on here, is that they can't sustain
in that small of a number, in that sort of
isolation, they can't sustain the different
specialized skills even to keep their existing
technologies alive. It's as if the hundred
or so people in this room were dumped on an
island, how many of the technologies in our
pockets would we still be able to make after
10,000 years? Obviously, not very many.
Tierra del Fuego is a very similar islands,
equally inhospitable, equally cold, equally
sparsely populated, and yet this didn't happen
here. Why not? Because the Magellan Straits
is narrower than the Bass Strait, and there
was continuous trading contact between the
people of Tierra del Fuego and the mainland
of South America, which there was not in Tasmania.
So my argument is this process of exchanges
specialization leads to something called collective
intelligence which transcends the power of
our brain. If you go back to the image again
of the hand ax and the mouse. The hand ax--as
I say--was made by one person for his own
use and he knew how to make it. Nobody knows
how to make a computer mouse. Quite literally,
I don't mean that figuratively I mean that
literally. There's nobody on the planet that
knows how to make a computer mouse. The president
of the computer mouse company only knows how
to run a company. But the person who assembles
it, he knows how to assemble it, but he doesn't
know how to drill an oil well to get the oil
and turn it into plastic. The knowledge is
not held in any one brain. And the brain cannot
comprehend that knowledge actually. We've
transcended the ability of our brains, because
we are able to use brains as nodes in a network,
I hope this is reverberating well at Google,
that's essentially what we're doing. We're
allowing--if I could go back to the analogy
between sex and exchange--we're allowing ideas
to have sex in this network, and come together
and combine and produce something that's greater
than the sum of its parts.
"Knowledge", said Friedrich Hayek, "never
exist in concentrated or integrated form,
but solely as the dispersed bits of incomplete
and frequently contradictory knowledge which
all us separate individuals possess." He is
arguing against central planning here and
it's basically the same point. So people are
nodes in a network and that's what lights
up the light bulb of human achievement. And
here of course, is where we get to the modern
world's where ideas are having sex in a furious
fashion compared with what ever went before.
Ideas can come together and combine and recombine
far faster than before and on a far bigger
scale than before. And if that is what drives
innovation, as I argued that it does, then
surely were going to see an acceleration of
innovation in this century not a diminution.
So I then want to tie all of this to an argument
that things are actually getting better. Now
very few people in my country seem to believe
this. Everybody thinks that things are getting
worse. And I used to be the same. I was brought-I
became an adult in the 1970s when Britain
was a pretty dire place and every one was
pretty pessimistic. I was told that the population
explosion was unstoppable, an epidemic of
cancer was beginning because the chemicals
in the environment, famine was going to reduce
the human population, nuclear war was on the
way, various diseases were coming back, the
oil was going to run out, and so on and so
forth. And I actually realized about the age
of 21 that nobody ever said anything optimistic
to me about the future of the human race at
all. Not in a pub or a television program
or anything. And I couldn't help noticing
some of these gloomy things just kept not
happening. And in fact, everything started
getting better. And all sorts of people started
getting richer and not only my country but
around the world. And I've been going back
and looking at the numbers on what's happened
in my lifetime, and I've astounded myself.
But this happens because we work for each
other we produce things for each other and
we make it cheaper for each other to achieve
things. So ask yourself how long it takes
you on the average wage in America or Britain,
it's roughly the same it turns out, to earn
an hour of ever reading light. That is to
say, an 18 watt compact fluorescent bulb burning
for about an hour which comes to about 1200
lumen-hours. Um. And the answer is that today
on the average wage you have to work for about
half a second to earn that much liked which
is not very long. In 1950 you'd have had for
16 times as long to earn that much light.
And in 1880 you'd have had to work a whole
15 minutes to earn an hour of reading light.
That was the cost of kerosene and the amortize
cost of a kerosene lamp. Back in 1800 and
you'd have to work for six hours--on the then
average wage--to earn the price of a candle
that gave you that much light. What that tells
you is that in 1800 the average person on
the average wage could not afford a candle.
And he certainly couldn't afford to sit reading
Jane Austen every night because he had worked
all day to achieve what he want it. And that's
just a measure of how extraordinarily much
technology has changed and improved our lives.
And here are some numbers: life expectancy
in my lifetime up roughly 30%, it's going
up at five hours per day, life expectancy.
This is global. This isn't America this it
is a all around the world. It's going up faster
in countries like China.
Poverty: this is one of several measures of
poverty, but they're all declining and they
all have been declining for at least 30 years.
That's true even in Africa. Africa had a couple
back decades in which the poverty rate actually
increase because population was going up faster
than economic growth. That's now turned around.
We've seen pretty steady progress in the diminution
of poverty in Africa--a long way to go--but
it's starting.
Air pollution: air pollution is halved in
the United States since 1980. A Ford Mustang
car in 1970 emitted more hydrocarbons sitting
on his driveway than a 2010 Mustang emits
try traveling at 70 miles an hour on the freeway.
Even oil spills.
Gasp!
How dare I say that with a British accent.
[audience laughs]
This is clearly going to be a terrible year
for oil spills. Its going to be one of the
big green bars on this year. Hopefully it
won't be too big but it it it it could be
at least half the size of some of the three
big ones. Are they green or yellow to you,
sorry? But notice the context. Which is, over
the past 30 years despite a huge increase
in the amount of oil transported on the ocean
the amount spilled has actually been going
down. Death rates from water related diseases,
they've virtually ceased to kill people in
the United States. Tuberculosis, scurvy, and
measles, other causes of death are not going
down as fast as infectious diseases but they're
not going up either. Where is this cancer
epidemic that we were promised from chemicals
in the environment. Age-adjusted cancer rates
are going down this shows non-age-adjusted
rates in there pretty level Heart disease
is going down. The AIDS epidemic came but
it has--to a degree--retreated. So just to
summarize, since 1955 life expectancy is up
a third, per capita income rate is up threefold,
that's corrected for inflation. Food per capita
is that the third, child mortality is down
two thirds, and population growth rate has
halved. That's in my lifetime. In the world
as a whole. And actually, I think people are
getting kind of less cruel, and less tolerant
of violence, more tolerant of difference and
ethnic differences and so on.
Some examples, the homicide rate in Europe
this is one of the crimes, one of violent
crimes can get fairly good data. And this
is Spierenburg's calculation for what the
homicide rate per hundred thousand people
was in Europe, even if it ticks up a bit it's
a long way short of your probability of being
a homicide victim in the Middle Ages. This
is an ancestral relation of mine called Bishop
Nicholas Ridley. He was burned at the stake
slowly--from the feet upwards--as a spectator
sport in 1555 for the crime of believing that
the sacrament, during the Communion, was figuratively
not literally the body of Christ. You know,
that was fun in those days you couldn't imagine
that nowadays. Of course, terrible horrible
violent things still happen in the world,
but on most measures they are actually getting
rarer and are getting harder to justify. Even
inequality is falling. Did you know that?
Most people think inequality is rising and
increment inequality has risen in countries
like the US but globally it's going down.
Why? Because poorer countries like China are
getting rich faster than rich countries are
getting rich. So finally, I don't think that
this process is over. I don't think that we're
like the man falling past the second floor
of the skyscraper who says, "So far so good."
[audience light laughter]
I think we ain't seen nothing yet. I don't
see any why this process of exchange and specialization
which produces new technologies will not continue
to improve people's lives in what comes ahead.
Just to give you one example of how ambitious
I think we should be about what to do in this
century to improve human lifestyles. If we
believe in progress, if we don't say we need
to stop now--and that is to say--ask yourself
how much land you need to feed a person on
the planet. If we were hunter gatherers we
would need a thousand hectares per head. Early
farmers used only about 10 hectares to feed
one person. That's how the density of human
people human population increased so dramatically
when farming was invented. By the 1950s we
were feeding people off of about 4000 m².
And today with the average cereal yield you
can produce enough calories on about 1200
m² to feed a person. So here's the global
cereal harvest over the last 50 years and
it's very nearly traveled over 50 years. And
yet the acreage that we plant in cereals has
not changed at all. And so of course, in increasing
the productivity of cereal growing land around
the world we've actually taken the pressure
off wild habitats. It's the increasing intensity
of farming that has actually save the rainforests.
And if we were to pull off the trick again--if
we could trebles yields from land again--and
I think it could be done with existing technology
let alone new ones, because there are large
parts of the world still not getting access
to fertilizers and things like that which
is what makes the difference.
Then what can we do in this century? Apparently
we crop about 15,000,000 km² which is almost
the size of Russia. If we were farming much
less efficiently, like early farmers we'd
need an awful lot more land. It couldn't be
done. We couldn't feed 9 billion people which
is how many there will be by the middle of
this century, from ah from that kind of agriculture.
Even if we went back to the type of agriculture
used in the 1950s we'd struggle, and even
with today's average yields we need more land
to feed 9 billion people in 2050 than we use
to feed 6.8 billion today. It stands to reason.
But if we were to double yields again in the
next 50 years, and as I say we jolly nearly
trebled them in the last 50 years. Then we
would actually be able to feed more people--that's
9 billion people--on less land than we cultivate
today. That means we can start to think about
rejoining rain forest patches, linking up
nature reserves, setting land aside, re-flooding
marshes that kind of thing. In fact, in some
of the rich Western countries we're already
doing that. That's the sort of ambition we
should have for technology and progress, and
by then population will be falling on most
projections. So actually if we did it again
in the following half-century we could imagine
feeding people from a still smaller patch
and giving even more land back to nature.
[pause]
So I think people who take a very pessimistic
view of the future are actually not going
to be right.
Certainly I'm not ruling out disasters. We
are certainly going to have horrible wars
in this century, I don't doubt it. We're going
to have depressions, we're going to have recessions,
we're going to have natural disasters. Horrible
things will happen. Ethnic conflicts all sorts
of things, just as we had in the 20th century.
But I think, after all population is only
an increase 1 1/2 times the century. It quadrupled
in the 20th century. It's going to get easier
and easier in that sense to improve people's
lives. This is what the preamble to Agenda
21, signed by the world leaders in Rio in
1992, started by saying. It said, "Humanity
stands as a defining moment in history. We
are confronted with a perpetuation of disparities
within and between nations a worsening of
poverty, hunger, ill health, illiteracy and
in the continued deterioration of the ecosystems
of which we depend for our well-being." With
the partial exception of the last parts of
that statement, everything in that statement
turned out to be utterly wrong about what
happened there for the next 18 years till
today. That is to say disparities within and
between nations got better not worse, poverty
got better not worse, hunger got better not
worse, ill health got better not worse, and
so on. Woody Allen put it this way rather
similarly, "more than at any time in our history,
mankind faces a crossroads. One path leads
to despair and utter hopelessness the other
to total extinction. Let us pray we have the
wisdom to choose carefully."
So there's the percentage increased population
in the world's population, it's almost halved
the early 60s, it's continuing to fall. And
why do we--why are we so pessimistic? My think
part of the problem is there's a conspiracy
to keep the good news from us. We only like
telling each other the bad news. Here's an
example from the New York Times, recently,
which is about an article that appeared in
the Lancet magazine on maternal mortality,which
is death in childbirth and pregnancy. Which
was falling for a while and then it leveled
out because of the AIDS epidemic and now it's
falling again. And when this was published
the editor of the Lancet came under a lot
of pressure not to publish from various pressure
groups. Because they were in the process of
arguing for funding increases to work on maternal
mortality and they didn't want the good news
out there spoiling their pitch. You can understand
the motivation of that. But I think it's just
a tiny example of how there is much more vested
interests in telling us bad news than telling
us good news. Another example, this is the
data that appeared in the intergovernmental
panel on climate change report in 2007. And
it shows the number of people who are likely
to be at increased water stress as a result
of four different scenarios of global warming
in the 21st century. And in each case it's
over a billion people who are likely to be
at increased water stress. But what they didn't
say in the 2007 report was that the paper
from which they got this data also had the
number of people that would be decreased water
stress as a result of each of these warming
scenarios. And not only is a number greater
in every case but its greatness the difference
is greatest in the warmest cases. So again
this is telling us only half the story. The
intergovernmental panel on climate change
uses economic assumptions to try and work
out how much carbon dioxide is going to be
produce in this century. And they--and this
is some of the--these are their four scenarios
for what GDP per capita will look like. And
obviously the highest scenario is the one
that produces the most carbon dioxide. But
it's worth reflecting that these are showing
increases in average GDP per capita of the
citizen's of the world between four and 18
times. And if we went on like we did in last
50 years then the average citizen of the world
would be nine times as rich--corrected for
inflation--in 2100 as he was in 1990. That's
a fairly interesting number, I think. I'm
just going to give you one example of why
I'm not that worried about climate change
one of many and are lots of reasons and lots
of subjects to discuss about this and I'm
not going to go into all of them in the depth.
But A. I don't see that climate change is
happening particularly fast, and I know that's
an un—an exceptional thing to say. And B.
I see no reason why human ingenuity is not
likely to lead to our ability to adapt to
it. As long as we take precautions and invest
in new technologies. Here's an example, this
is the United States average temperature over
the last century. And the rural data is a
dark blue line and urban data is the pink
line. So very clearly you can see the postwar
heat island effect. How okay sorry the color
is completely different. The blue line is
urban data and the black line is the rural
data. What a strange projector you have here
[laughs, audience laughs]. It looks quite
different on my screen. So you can see the
urban heat island effect--which we all know--which
is the cities with all the concrete get warmer
than the countryside. But that's the unadjusted
raw data. When that stuff is published and
put into the international record, the rural
data is adjusted upwards rather than urban
data adjusted downwards. I find that very
puzzling. But either way it's not particularly
fast change in temperature. And here's why--even
on theoretical grounds--I think it's perfectly
legitimate to be a complete believer in the
greenhouse effect, as I am. And still not
be convinced that were in the face of catastrophic
warming in this century had anything like
a high probability. Everybody agrees on how
much warming a doubling of carbon dioxide
will produce and its about a degree. But the
3° prediction that we're all given from the
intergovernmental panel on climate change
comes from a water vapor feedback and two
extra degrees. And that comes about because
the 1° will produce more evaporation therefore
there'll be more water in the air and water
is a greenhouse gas too, fair enough. But
water also forms clouds and clouds can reflect
sunlight back into space. And some of the
data that is now coming in a showing that
that water vapor feedback is not likely to
be so large. And it may not even be positive
in all it may even be negative. In which case,
the net warming would be less. So there's
no disagreement about the blue bit there is
huge disagreement about the green bits and
therefore there's big disagreement about the
red bit that were facing. Anyway, I didn't
want to get bogged down on climate change.
I just wanted to give you a couple reasons
why--after looking at as much of it is possible--I
have come to the conclusion that, yes it's
possible that we face catastrophe but, no
I'm not yet worried that is likely. Of course
all this optimism is no good because optimism
sounds silly and pessimism sounds wise "I've
observed," said John Stuart Mill,"that not
the man who hopes when others despair but
the man he despairs when others hope is admired
by a large class of persons as a sage."
Thank you very much.
[audience applause]
>>male presenter #2:Alright if you have some
questions just gather at the microphone here.
Yup, that one there.
>>man in audience#1: Hi. I noticed that you
didn't mention anything about the topic of
energy. Obviously it's important questions,
I'm wondering why he skipped that. You know,
if you have bacteria in a petri dish and a
supply of energy you will see growth. And
a lot of the charts you showed for progress--if
you plot progress--some measure of progress
as a present danger of availability of cheap
energy, some of the commentators have said
that is actually falling if you plot GDP versus
available resources in terms of oil or whatever.
Ridley: Yeah, yeah. It's a very good question
and in the longer version of this talk I do
have some charts on energy. You are absolutely
right, cheap energy made this possible. The
reason the last 200 years have been so good--we
had improvements before that--but the last
200 years have been so good because the inexhaustible
fossil fuels that did not get more expensive
the more you used them like wood did, like
charcoal did, coal in particular came along
in the industrial Industrial Revolution in
Britain. It turned out there were--as it were--limitless
supplies of coal at the same price and eventually
the price even fell for most. So, yes cheap
energy makes all the difference. And each
of us sitting here today consumes the equivalent
in fossil fuel energy or at least electricity
and other kinds of energy of having roughly
600 slaves in the back room on exercise bicycles
working for us. Which was how you had a rich
lifestyle if you were a Bronze Age emperor
of course. You actually literally had the
600 slaves working for you.
So, in that sense I think the appearance of
cheap energy has made an enormous impact on
our lives. And enabled us to work for each
other in a way that doesn't involve the exploitation
of people to the same extent. So that's one
point. But the second point is will it all
run out? Will all come grinding to a halt
very soon? And I think in terms of the three
big sources of fossil fuels: coal, oil, and
gas which give us about 88% of the world's
energy use at the moment. Therefore, they're
the big ones to talk about. There's no question
that there's enough coal to last for many
centuries yet. It's simply a matter of how
deep you dig. And there are all sorts of ways
coming on stream for getting down to deeper
seams of coal and getting gas out of them
rather than having to dig out the coal themselves.
So, I don't think there's any chance of running
out of coal. At least not before we've invented
things to take its place.
Gas had looked a little more finite until
a few years ago. The shale gas revolution
that has transformed the United States gas
supplies is quite extraordinary. In the last
five or 10 years America has gone from thinking
it had about 20 to 30 years of gas left to
realizing it's probably got 50 to 150 years
of gas left, because of the ability to get
gas outs of shale. And that's a relatively
cheap technology, and now they're trying it
in Europe and they're expecting to find huge
reserves of the stuff in China too. So it's
not looking like gas is going to run out anytime
soon. And by the way gas is a low carbon fuel
compared with coal and oil. CH4, you're burning
a lot more hydrogen than carbon when you burn
it.
Oil looks more finite. It looks like were
going to run out of oil a lot sooner than
we are of the others. Not literally runs out
because there are huge reserves of very expensive
forms of oil like the tar sands in Alberta
and so on. They really will last 100-200 years
at some point but at a price. And I think
there is no question, at some point we are
likely to see oil getting more and more expensive.
The question is will that actually start to
pinch off human living standards before we
have invented cheap alternatives? And I don't
think it will because I think for a start
you can substitute cheap gas for a lot of
the uses of oil. You can make petroleum out
of coal if necessary. You know, we're leaving
aside the sort of climate consequences to
all of this. I'm just talking about the costs
of energy. So I rather support what, I've
forgotten his name, the guy who's just written
a book called Power Hungry. It says--which
is--this century is going to be "N2N", as
he calls, it natural to gas and nuclear. That's
sort of the--the source of most of our energy
in this century. Long answer, good question.
Thanks for the question.
>>man in audience #2: You had a good statistic
on homicide rates, but I'm curious about wars.
Do you have any statistics on say, you know,
per capita the number of people that die in
wars?
>>Matt Ridley: Yeah, that's a really good
question. The answer is, you know the 20th
century deaths per capita in wars were bad.
I don't need to tell you that you already
knew that. 200 million people killed in wars
in the 20th century compared with many fewer
in the 19th century. But nearly all of that
happened in the first half of the 20th century.
There were about 20 million people killed
in wars in the second half of the century
about 180 million in the first half. So, you
know, we went to a very very bad 50-year patch.
But even if you take that 50 years and you
say this is your probability of dying in war.
It was roughly 1/10 of your probability of
dying in war you lived in a hunter gatherer
society in Brazil or Papua New Guinea. Hunter-gatherer
warfare is a low grade thing with a lot of
skirmishing and a lot of posturing and the
odd throwing of things that results in a surprisingly
large number of deaths per head of population,
even compared with industrialized warfare
in the 20th century. So yeah, by 1950 the
trend had got a lot worse on wars over the
last couple of hundred years. It looks like
it's gotten a lot better again in the last
50 years. Which we will go in this century
I don't know. But it's a you know, it's wise
to be cautious, about that I agree.
>>man in audience #3: Do we have time for
one more question...
>>man in audience #3: You say you're an optimist's,
but do you functioned as a futurist as well.
Do you subscribe to the singularity or anything
like this?
>>Matt Ridley: Well, it's a good question,
and I'm looking at Stephen because we were
talking about this earlier. And the answer
is that I kind of duck that at the end of
the book. In other words, I say I don't see
any reason why these good things can't continue
but I'm not going to try specify what the
future's going to look like. Why? Because
every futurologists I've ever read is looks
awfully silly 50 years later. I hope that's
not true of Ray Kurzweil and people like that.
But if you look at HG Wells or Isaac Asimov
or George Orwell or anything, you know, Aldous
Huxley
they're writing about their own time. They're
not writing about the future actually. So
for example the 1950s everyone predicted by
now we would have an incredible transport
revolution. We'd all have personal gyrocopter's
and space travel would be routine and supersonic
aircraft would be routine. They were completely
wrong about that transport in the turned out
to be a technology that stagnate in terms
of rate of speed of transport.
>>man in audience #4: And what about the information
explosion?
Ridley: Exactly, and what they didn't spot
was that communication was going to have this
explosion. So I feel at some point this communication
revolution will run out of steam as the transport
one did. Steam is wrong word but you know
what I mean. Some time around the middle of
this century, perhaps. But by than some other
technology will be expanding rapidly. I don't
know what it will be. It'll probably be biotech
or something related to biology. But all I
know is that as Yogi Berra, the baseball player,
was supposed to have once said, "I never make
predictions especially about future."
>>male presenter #2: Thank you. So we'll have
some time at the end of the talk if you have
any other additional questions. But for now
Matt thank you for an amazing talk at Google.
>>Matt Ridley: Okay. Thank you.
[audience applause]